in terms of designing confident
architectures one of the ideas that
really hopes is using a one by one
convolution now you might be wondering
what is the one by one convolution do
isn't that just multiplying by a number
is that it seems like a funny thing to
do turns out it's not quite like that
let's take a look you see one by one
filter put the number two there and if
you take this 6x6 image 6 by 6 by 1 and
convolve it with this one by one by one
filter you end up just taking the image
and multiplying by 2 so 1 2 3 ends up
being 2 4 6 and so on and so a
convolution by a 1 by 1 filter it
doesn't seem totally useful you just
multiply it by some number but that's
the case of 6 by 6 by 1 channel
images if you have a 6 by 6 by 32
instead of by 1 then a convolution with
a 1 by 1 filter can do something that
makes much more sense and in particular
what a 1 by 1 convolution will do is it
will look at each of the 36 different
positions here and it will take the
element wise product between 32 numbers
on the left and the 32 numbers in the
filter and then apply a value
non-linearity to it after that so to
look at one of the 36 positions maybe
one slice through this volume you take
these 36 numbers multiply it by you know
one by one slice through the volume like
that and you end up with a single real
number which then gets plotted in one of
the outputs like that and in fact one
way to think about the 32 numbers you
have in this one but 1 by 32 filter is
that is as if you have one neuron that
is taking us input 32 numbers
multiplying each of these 32 numbers in
one slice in the same position height
and width but these 32 different channel
multiplying them by 32 weights and then
applying a really non-linearity to it
and then outputting the corresponding
thing over there and more generally if
you have not just one filter but if you
have multiple filters then it's as if
you have not just one unit but multiple
units that are taking as input all the
numbers in one slice and then building
them up into an output there the 66 by
six by number of filters so one way to
think about the one by one convolution
is that it is basically having a fully
connected neural network that applies to
each of the 62 different positions and
what does fully fermented neural network
does is it inputs 32 numbers and outputs
you know number of filters outputs so I
guess the pinyin notation this is really
a NC of L plus 1 if that's the next
layer and by doing this at each of the
36 positions each of the 6 by 6
positions you end up with an output that
is 6 by 6 by the number of filters and
this can carry out a pretty non-trivial
computation on your input volume and
this idea is often called a 1 by 1
convolution but is sometimes also called
Network in network and is described in
this paper by Midland champion and
shriek and yam and even though the
details of the architecture in this
paper are used widely
this idea of a one-by-one convolution of
this sometimes called network of network
idea has been very influential has
influenced many other neural network
architectures including the inception
network which we'll see in the next
video but to give you an example of
where one by one convolution is useful
here's something you could do of it
let's say you have a Tony by Tony 8 by
192 volume if you want to shrink the
height
with you can use a pooling layer so we
know how to do that but what if the
number of channels has gotten too big
and you want to shrink that how do you
string ker into a 28 by 28 by 32
dimensional volume well what you can do
is use 32 filters that are one by one
and technically each filter would be of
dimension one by one by 192 because the
number of channels in your filter has to
match the number of channels in your
input volume but you use 32 filters and
the output of this process will be a 28
by 28 by 32 volume so this is a way to
let your shrink and see as well where as
pooling layers I use just a shrink 1/8
and NW the height and width of these
volumes and we'll see later how this
idea of one-by-one convolutions allows
you to shrink the number channels and
therefore save on computation and some
networks but of course if you want to
keep the number of channels to the 192
that's fine too and the effect of a 1 by
1 convolution is it just has
non-linearity it allows you to learn the
more complex function of your network by
adding another layer the inputs 20 by 20
by 192 and output is 20 by 20 by 192 so
that's how a 1 by 1 convolutional layer
is actually doing something pretty
non-trivial and it has non-linearity to
in your network and allow you to
decrease or keep the same or if you want
increase the number of channels in your
volumes next you see that this is
actually very useful for building the
inception Network let's go on to that in
the next video so you've now seen how a
one by one convolution operation is
actually doing a pretty non-trivial
operation and allows you to shrink the
number of channels in your volumes or
keep it the same or even increase it if
you want in the next vid video you see
that this can be used to help build up
to the inception
Network let's go onto the next video